truly we have found America's dog
this is that polite that's a video of
Boston Dynamics spot mini quadropod
robot opening a door for a friend it's
adorable well unless that other robot is
female then it's clearly sexist anyway
this is impressive stuff perhaps too
impressive see this technology it can go
two ways first as our non conscious
allies robots can do good rescue loved
ones from hostages and earthquakes while
also assisting the invalid they can
replace humans in other high-risk
endeavors like war they likely won't be
traditional BOTS though but swarms of
insect like drones that can get into
places that men can't but the second
more disturbing path is of a non
conscious goal-oriented creature with
computation speeds beyond our
comprehension
once Unleashed we can't stop them if
their goal is simply to open a door it
may want to open all doors and may
dispense with us to do so it's nothing
personal
you're just in their way we become
barnyard chickens the metal gods are
merciless farmers but I digress I
welcome our robot overlords fact is
robots and artificial intelligence can
only be our allies as long as we get
there first
before everyone else because the country
that reaches superiority in this arena
rules and rules the planet forever this
is bigger than the a-bomb to be scared
of progress is natural but the only
thing more frightening is living in the
country that comes in second you get you
get my point Dana if let's say China
beats us in this the China is the number
one country in the world no we should
need to be first yes absolutely all the
money everything should be focused on it
but I don't think we're set up for that
really no spending trillions about I'm
worried about this
I am worried worried worried Jessie my
scary part is the country that doesn't
perfect this technology might get there
first creating a creature that is evil
and unstoppable and then we all die like
terminator me yes when I saw the video
the first thing I wanted to do is shoot
the dog
no I would shoot it I would shoot the
whole thing I would shoot it and shoot
it and shoot it
I told smoke came out of it and then I'd
feel safe because the guy that I share
an office with it's kind of a tech geek
and he said people can hack into these
things and then you could put cameras in
these things they could record all the
things you're doing so I don't trust
these things I like them as a servant or
a butler but if they turn that I'd shoot
them it's like a LexA with legs yes I
think if you're gonna shoot it I would
suggest going for center mass and spring
what is wrong with you people
robots when you're looking at let's say
it's like 2050 right now you're looking
at this show remember I defended you
so come for me last kill them for I'm
Sarah Connor I'm coming for you first
one there's gonna be all kinds of
litigation with these things right yeah
that guy opens the door and there might
slam it on somebody's face legal system
well it would I mean to me that's a
secondary issue the primary issue is
what you just described which is their
opening doors and doing things and they
got cameras in them yeah so Elon Musk
says you know what we've gotta merge
with them right instead of worrying
about them taking over we got to figure
out how we work with them or become one
with them so that our brains whatever I
can never get their security at the
airport then well maybe because you have
something implanted your head Jesse you
wouldn't have to go through secure they
know who you are yeah you know what it
is it's if you got a look at this ass
like the way we evolved from primitive
man this is the next evolution we are we
are Neanderthal compared to this so we
might as well get used to it I don't
think you can meld a machine with man
because it's wet meat with electronics
anchor2 work
you're already wielding you're already
melding it with your phones ships in
your body I don't know if like but it's
a matter I already do put chips in my
body
they're called Doritos